od toward our country's welfare the war
is singing its last verse and it
requires every effort from all who would
call themselves men you will understand
that won't you
we have had so many magical happy years
and my highest wish is to continue that
happy life together but should the
Almighty have another course for me know
that my last thought was of you time is
short but if all will not go well don't
feel sorry for me I am completely happy
and thankful for what I have had in life
even though I very much would like to
live to help Norway back to its feet I
wish the best for tsatsa land life I
look forward to seeing them all again
and then the letter was signed your
beloved that was life John step thank
you very much
let's see this is
I'll try that one alright so we've we've
got a time for a few questions if
anybody has questions for Neil I'm sure
there must be one or two out there all
right while you're pondering your
questions I'm gonna cert my prerogative
in to ask the first one so these
Norwegian commandos were human not you
know not Superman but pretty remarkable
individuals who did something really
amazing after the war did they go and
become plumbers again what I imagine men
who are capable of doing this sort of
thing and then who do it you know I
imagined them you know going into the
military or becoming war correspondents
or you know something like that do you
know anything about their sort of
post-war lives sure some of them
continued in the military for instance
palsun did how glad did Ronin Burk
became a broadcaster Klaus Hallberg was
for many seasons a tour guide in Nevada
they all took sort of different courses
but what I would say about their
post-war lives are two things one these
episodes in this life that they lived
they're sort of imprinted itself on them
sometimes in in in haunting ways
einar's skin and the Shannons daughter
told me that you would never approach
Einar from behind because he was always
he had lived on the ground he had lived
in a cabin where at any moment the
Germans could come and he never lost
that some of them went to sort of heal
their wounds by going into the woods for
four weeks at a time
I think Newt Haugland has the sort of in
some ways the most extraordinary story
because he and himself felt wounded
psychologically after all this time and
he decided to join the lived quite a
life he joined the kontiki expedition he
was the radio operator on the kontiki
so he you know lived another
extraordinary life and I think they all
did in their own ways the other thing I
would say is they were very tight-knit
most of them over the course of the rest
of their lives many of them gathered
every year at a hunting cabin in the
south and talked war stories but also
just I think in some ways nobody else
understood them yeah gentlemen right
here in their front row if you'll hold
on one second we've got a microphone
coming for c-span thank you so much for
your interesting and thoughtful
presentation
my name is Abraham hoping to serve at
the American Embassy in Oslo and recall
visiting the underground underground
museum and I cannot refuse I recall
there was a mention of this episode are
they there the bombing of the heavy
water facility and this museum is
documented the first act of resistance
was for the sinking of the troop carrier
the Blucher which sank 1,500 the german
when they enter the oslo fjord on April
the 9th 1940 we're not able to catch
they didn't have enough force to capture
the city they also and that enabled the
King to escape so that underground
museum but there was a major source of
inspiration and information about the
resistance to the Nazi occupation now I
think I absolutely agree with you I mean
the Norwegian resistance museum was both
a absolute resource for me I mean their
archives are tremendous and I I focus on
this story of their MOOC and I talked
about the Norwegian independent company
but I think also post-war to a man these
individuals says their most important
job was not very much it was other
operations they were on there were quite
a number of company leaing or Norwegian
independence men many of them lost their
lives they participated in scores of
operations and if you read life trance
that's Diaries ver MOOC is definitely in
there it's in there you know every month
or so there's a little mention of it but
there's the litany of other operations
they all were named
after many of them were named after
birds so there's you know it's very it's
a fascinating the whole story of the
Norwegian and independent company the
young gentleman in the third row in from
the aisle
well well all right tell you what we'll
take what we'll take both of them they
both have their hands up
go ahead what's a mind field and if we
want to get the e1 from here as well
if the Germans kept making the heavy
water why didn't they continue with the
bomb program so the minefield first of
all a minefield is basically the Germans
and other other countries they they put
these explosives underneath the ground
okay and they have a setting that can
explode them and many of them most of
them were taken away after the war
pretty much all of them in the various
oh they're totally safe now
the question about the like how does it
react like explode how does it explode
in many circumstances it's the weight so
let's say you let's say an animal is is
going through a minefield if if a hoof
stepped on it that weight would trigger
it to go off the question of what did
they continue to do because the Germans
reconstituted the plant
the Allies in some ways got their way
there was a major bombing mission with
hundreds of b-17 and b25 bombers exactly
what Tron's that predicted hat would
happen happened the plant was not
touched a number of civilians were
killed but the the consequence of that
although the heavy water facility was
not stopped the Germans decided at that
point I read a report that one German
official sent from from rukon to Berlin
saying the Norwegians have made a
national sport quote unquote
of of sabotaging their look we need to
move it and so you find that in February
the February of 1944 they in fact begin
to dissemble the plant begin to bring
all the heavy water into barrels and as
I mentioned very briefly that sets the
stage for the last-minute sabotage that
neut how could perform to and once and
for all the German use of heavy water
from Norway other questions
join in the back there well we'll come
back to forget a chance was there any
connection or contact between these
people and their efforts and Moberg the
American baseball player and linguist
who was supposed to serve a Werner
Heisenberg yes so no I love the story of
Moberg you know baseball player turned
spy there's a wonderful book called the
the catcher is a spy I believe that's
the the time I was a spy and his mission
and it's one of the reasons I actually
turned onto this topic because I found
that so fascinating that that Moe would
go to Germany and his the plan was if
Heisenberg if it was clear that
Heisenberg was participating in these
potentially to kill him but he had no
contact at all this was the American OSS
handling these operations and the
was a clear demarcation between the SOE
and the OSS in terms of Norway in these
operations other questions all right
we'll take we'll take one more here and
then we'll we'll call it an evening
right what does heavy water look like
ooh good that's a fantastic question it
looks exactly like regular water you
can't tell the difference it looks just
like this and in fact one could argue
there's heavy water in a very small
quantity in here there's one molecule
for every 41 million molecules of
regular water but it looks the same and
some say it tastes the same but I don't
suggest drinking it it does
scientists have have shown sort of if
you drink it in large quantities change
some biological processes which is one
of the reasons they built the plant is
because they thought one of the heads of
norske dro thought that heavy water
would cure cancer it is not proven to do
that but it looks just the same well on
that now let me just let me just mention
for those of you who didn't see it when
we come in I believe we have back there
downstairs yes Laura the the nice young
lady waving her hand has a vial of heavy
water from norsk hydro which you can
look at nearby is also a some Sun drinks
and refreshments which as far as I need
to know do not contain heavy water for
which we can thank the Norwegian Embassy
thank you very much so I hope you will
join us at the reception and let's
please all and end the book signing
thank you you can get your book signed
down there you can have a drink you can
chat with the ill chat with our friends
from the Norwegian Embassy thank you for
coming and have a have a great evening
thank you everyone
[Music]
book TV is on Instagram follow us for
publishing news schedule updates and
behind-the-scenes pictures and videos
instagram.com
slash book underscore TV
Steve fast is the publicity manager for
the University of Illinois press Steve
what new books you have coming out this
fall well we have a lot of great titles
coming out in this fall including one
that is a look at the history of the
Atlantic slave trade it's called slavery
at sea Shawanda Muscatine is the author
and it's really one of the first
in-depth looks at the mechanics of
slavery at sea and the making of slaves
as they were being transported in
bondage from one continent to North
America and it really shows how this
dehumanizing process happens
step-by-step and explains a lot of how
the process of slavery transformed the
spirits of people to be put in that
position and that'll be coming out in
November what else you got
we also have a book by Michael solo
which looks at the 1936 Olympics those
are commonly called the Nazi Olympics
the book is called six minutes in Berlin
some people may be familiar with the
story of the American rowing team that
won the gold medal that year of course
people know Jesse Owens of course
winning the gold medal as well that
Olympics really was the first time that
the worldwide sports media business got
started and the six minutes in Berlin
are the six minutes that that race took
broadcast live around the world for the
rowers to win and defeat the favored
Nazi rowers Steve can you give me a
little history of the University of
Illinois press and what what books do
you publish well we are approaching in
2018 our 100th year of publishing out of
the University of Illinois we represent
all three campuses of the University of
Illinois were based in Champaign Urbana
but we also represent the Chicago campus
and the Springfield campus and we've
been publishing in a variety of subjects
over those 100 years as you may have
thought from what we were just talking
about history is a strong subject for us
music and American roots music are big
subjects for us as well as labor history
african-american history and a number of
other titles give me one more title for
this fall one more title this fall that
is really exciting and interesting is a
little bit of an expansion from our work
in Mormon studies and it's called
bearing witness
it's an edited collection that Holly
Welker has put together and it is the
firsthand stories of 36 Mormon women in
all spectrum of the faith representing
different stories of how they deal with
marriage how they deal with love how
they deal with sex how they deal with
marrying outside of the Mormon religion
and the pressures that come in some
cases to have a very traditional Mormon
relationship and it's a very interesting
book and ties in with some of our
feminist Media Studies books what is
that coming out that is coming out the
howlin is coming out in September Steve
fast is a publicity manager for the
University of Illinois press when I tune
in to it on the weekends usually its
authors sharing up their new releases
watching the nonfiction authors on book
TV is the best television for serious
readers on c-span they can have a longer
conversation and delve into their
subject
book TV weekends they bring you author
after author after author that spotlight
the work of fascinating people
I love book TV and I'm a c-span fans my
name is Howard Unger and on behalf of
the United States Holocaust Memorial
Museum it is my honor to welcome you to
today's program titled a relentless
pursuit bringing Holocaust perpetrators
to justice I am the son of a Holocaust
survivor and have served on the council
for the US Holocaust Museum for the past
five years I have come to learn that the
museum is so much more than just a
building that houses exhibits the museum
researches history trained educators
members of the military and the
judiciary
both in the US and internationally and
has many programs focused on preventing
future genocides from occurring again
here in New York
the museum's northeast regional office
offers a variety of events including
talks like the one you are about to hear
plus film screenings and programs on
Holocaust history as well as
contemporary genocide and anti-semitism
tomorrow we will be holding this same
program at Bottari synagogue in Mount
Kisco New York
so please PLEASE encourage your
Westchester friends and family to join
us there tomorrow evening at 7:45
tonight's program is part of a
conversation that the u.s. Holocaust
Memorial Museum is holding nationwide
examining the role each of us has when
confronted with difficult and complex
challenges only in recent history has
international law evolved to define and
punish mass violence against civilians
added the devastating crimes of the
Holocaust the Allied powers were forced
to bring state actors to justice for
unspeakable crimes never before tried in
a court of law
a small percent of percentage of Nazi
officials and collaborators were brought
to trial in the immediate post-war
period as the years passed the global
legal community largely lost interest in
pursuing the remaining
perpetrators however a few remarkable
individuals continue to work to bring
Nazi criminals to justice and these
later trials continue to influence
international law law grows through the
setting of precedents in other words how
judges apply the law helps determine
what the law means through the judgments
of these tribunals and courts
international law on genocide and crimes
against humanity evolves deepening our
understanding of the crimes and our
capacity to respond today our
outstanding panel will discuss how these
precedents were created and applied the
figures who'd helped carry them out and
the ongoing legacy of this history it is
now my pleasure to introduce our special
guest and Runa Gorski journalist and
author of the new book the Nazi hunters
and dr. Lawrence Douglas chair of law
jurisprudence and social thought and at
Amherst College and author of the right
wrong man John DeMille yoke and the last
great Nazi war crimes trial our
moderator of this evening is dr.
Elizabeth white historian with the
United States Holocaust Memorial Museum
she goes by buries when you hear them
talking to her that way you'll
understand following the program both
authors will be outside in the lobby to
sign copies of their books thank you
[Applause]
hey good evening everyone and just so
we're straight on who's who I'm dr.
Elizabeth beary white this is Lawrence
Douglas and Andrew Nagurski thank you
all for coming out tonight and thank you
both for participating in this program
brutal atrocities have been a feature of
warfare since the dawn of human history
and to the extent that perpetrators were
ever made to account for their actions
it was through Victor's justice acts of
reputation by the winning side against
the losers but during World War two the
Allies signaled that they were going to
take a different approach late in 1943
as it became clear that Nazi Germany was
going to lose the war the leaders of the
United States Great Britain and the
Soviet Union announced that the
perpetrators of Nazi atrocities would be
brought to trial under the laws of the
countries where they committed their
crimes and that the major Nazi
leadership in criminals would face joint
punishment by the Allies and II did did
this signal that the Allies had
definitely decided that they were going
to forgo vengeance in favor of justice
and what did they hope to accomplish by
putting Nazi criminals on trial well not
really in the sense that justice and
vengeance were inevitably intertwined at
the end of the war and remember 1943 the
Moscow declaration that you cited there
was a lot of fighting ahead all the way
to Berlin and a lot of was very vicious
and especially the Red Army had had
suffered massive losses and they were
they were getting revenge among others
by not just on the military but for
instance rapes and advised by the Red
Army are estimated to be it close to 2
million in Germany but there you had
that
operation which was a novel idea that
instead of you just exact vengeance you
do seek justice but right away six weeks
later at the Tehran conference Stalin
says to Roosevelt and Churchill well I
have an idea of justice let's line up
50,000 are a hundred thousand of the top
German commanders and let's shoot them
that will be justice Churchill was
horrified and Roosevelt says something
like oh let's have a compromise let's
shoot forty nine thousand five hundred
didn't go over well with Churchill but
what's interesting it goes back and
forth and eventually Stalin and
Roosevelt decide they do want two trials
for different reasons Stalin love show
trials in the in the 30s he had show
trials they are fake trials and by
Roosevelt really wanted this principle
and Churchill was aware of the danger
and a trap of show trials and he
suddenly in some recently declassified
documents we found out that at one point
he was considering a plan to just have
summary executions of a few top leaders
and and and some just imprisoned without
trial so this went back and forth
eventually the trials happened as we
know Nuremberg Dachau and so forth and I
it was it was unprecedented but every
step of the way has been controversial
right up to today's mm-hmm and what did
they I mean what were the reasons they
opted to go for the trials as theirs
were their particular goals besides just
holding people accountable yeah aside
from her just holding people accountable
and the obvious one if somebody has to
be punished for all the horrors
there was the educational element was
there very early and President Truman
said right at one point what these
trials are meant to do is to make it
impossible to suffer someone to say now
or any time in the future that these
things didn't happened and that's why
immediately you had at the trials
documents film witnesses in some cases
witnesses in some cases documentation
but it was to set the record straight
because so many people were in denial
but what had happened of course
especially in Germany in Austria but
elsewhere in the world people were only
beginning to grasp the magnitude of what
had happened so it was a particular
focus than on the German people to kind
of show them the evils that had been
done in their name then yes yes that was
the priority at first and why we fought
this war and and but there was a media
opposition for instance the United
States there was opposition to the
trials both from the left and the right
saying this is Victor's justice which
was the line of many Germans at first
but for the people who went into the
concentration camps for instance and
liberated them they said no this is not
Victor's justice this is just justice
yeah
Lawrence you're our legal expert here
the charges before the International
Military Tribunal at Nuremberg were
crimes against peace war crimes and
crimes against humanity at least some of
these were new terms did the
international legal community consider
these to be well-founded in existing law
were some of them particularly
controversial well as Andy said I mean
the whole trial was involved in
controversy and we have to remember that
this was the first International
Criminal Court in human history and in
certain respects not only were the 21
individual defendants on trial but law
itself was on trial that is to the
extent that the Allies had committed to
doing a trial program as opposed to
summary education they really had to
demonstrate that law was an adequate
tool for dealing with crimes of this
magnitude and so they wanted to
certainly make sure that whatever
charges were brought against these
defendants that they had adequate
grounding in international law now that
said I think we need to bear in mind
that the Nuremberg trial that famous one
before the International Tribunal was
not in the first instance a holocaust
trial as you mentioned the the principal
charge that was brought against the
defendants at Nuremberg was that they
had waged an aggressive war in violation
of international law and that charge of
waging an aggressive war that has not
showed a lot of durability
since Nuremberg and even at the time
it was very much involved in controversy
and use the term Victor's justice and
Victor's justice was most particularly
applied to the charge of waging an
aggressive war because the question
emerged since when in human history was
waging war a crime it might be something
we don't like it might be something we
disagree with but since when was it a
crime the other charges that were
brought war crimes war crimes was pretty
well established in international law
and then crimes against humanity in my
mind was the most distinctive
contribution that Nuremberg made it was
through the channel of this relatively
new thing called crimes against humanity
that most of the evidence of the crimes
of the Holocaust entered the Nuremberg
trial and I think we can say now with
70-plus years of hindsight that crimes
against humanity was the most
distinctive and important legal
breakthrough of the Nuremberg trial and
crimes against humanity
included what kinds of action it
basically included what we can describe
as extermination systematic attacks on a
civilian population we have to remember
that genocide which is I think a term
that we all would use today to describe
the Nazis exterminate horry practices
genocide was only coined as a term in
1944 a year before the trial started it
was coined by Raphael Lemkin who of
course was a legal adviser Polish Jewish
legal advisor to the US War Department
and so even though today genocide stands
as an independent crime in international
law at the time of Nuremberg it was
still very much a very new term and it
doesn't merge in the trial itself if you
look for in particularly at the closing
arguments of the prosecutors they start
to use this new term but that new term
of genocide is basically used as a
description of the Nazis crimes against
humanity yeah I think it was in the
indictment exactly in indictment it's
mentioned as a war crime and then in the
closing arguments of the lawyers of the
prosecutors then they start describing
it as a crime against humanity yeah
well if you're going to hold trials you
have to present ever
to support the charges and so late in
the war the United States Army formed
war crimes investigative teams his
mission it was to accompany combat
troops as they fought their way across
Germany and to seize and collect
evidence of Nazi war crimes so let's
take a look at how this worked of
according to Nuremberg prosecutor Ben
Firenze
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
between 1945 and 1948 there were
thousands of trials of Nazi criminals by
the Allies in Germany but also by the
countries that suffered under German
occupation Andy you've written about
some of the trials can you highlight
some that you think were particularly
significant or controversial well there
are several but I'll point to three and
I'll start maybe instead of I'll get
back to Ben forensics moment but with
one in point with Poland where there was
an investigator by the name of Yan Sen
who was interesting he was from a Polish
family of German origin
he's as I discovered researching his
story it turns out that his his brother
during the occupation that actually
registered as a folk story as an ethnic
German and became the mayor of a small
town and then disappeared after the war
Johnson was a lawyer who though who is
not did not couldn't did not do that and
he became the most fervent war crimes
investigator in Poland and he was the
one for instance those of you of course
know from Schindler's List almond girth
the the concentration camp commander of
pascha of near Krakow he was the one who
had him hanged but most importantly his
most important prisoner was Rudolf Hess
the
the longest serving serving commandant
of Auschwitz and what was interesting he
was already representing a regime a
communist imposed regime so if he had
gone by sort of the Stalin rules
he would have summoned the guy how to
make a quick statement hang him
instead he spent days weeks months
getting getting coaxing Hess to write
his whole life story in the story of the
camp and it is the most I think the most
chilling document of the Holocaust
because here is hessed
explaining how he's just this
functionary and he's working so hard and
he's hurting kids and men and women into
the gas chambers and but I'm working so
hard that I don't have time to play with
my own kids across the yard it is and
it's beginning sin understood the value
of these trials is to get this on record
and everybody he tried he got it on
record and later on it would be the
basis say for the Auschwitz trials of
guards in Germany as well so yon Santa
and his trial there of course Hess was
hanged in 1947 but as much as the
verdict and and and the outcome I think
is it's what that produced then been
friends for those of you don't know been
friends is still life he's 96 years old
he is incredible he's about five feet
tall and he is an amazing person when I
went to see him with my wife in in
Delray Beach Florida
he had just back from the gym and he's
showing my wife his biceps and and he
got that he became at age 27 the young
and that the prosecutor in what was
called the Einsatzgruppen case the Isis
grouping or these special killing squads
the Nazis sent out to the Eastern Front
before the gas chambers were operational
so this was the form of mass murder and
has been described it a researcher found
all the records the Germans were
scrupulous they had the records how many
people were killed in this village this
day and how many the next day and he
said I sat down on my pocket
Calcavecchia
now pocket calculator adding machine and
when I reached 1 million I stopped
counting and he goes to tell for tale or
the chief prosecutor for these follow-up
trials and he says we've got to try
these guys we've got chapter and verse
and Taylor says oh you know we don't
really have it budgeted I don't even
have a prosecutor for this we've got all
the the follow-up trials arranged he
said well I prosecute it and he does
that at age 27 in that case we're in
many very well educated commanders of
these Isis group and is just a
fascinating morbid case but it's also a
show and kappa latex absolutes what
happened 13 of the 22 he had on in the
doc were sentenced to death
eventually only four of them were hanged
because of successive amnesty stand by
1958 the rest were out finally as though
the one other case I'll briefly mention
it William Denson who was a another
young US Army prosecutor and he
conducted the the doc out trials which
was not just of the personnel in Dachau
but of other concentration camps and
this was to get the people who were
actually they are carrying out the is
the worst work of yeah really treating a
killing torturing prisoners and he he
espoused the theory called common design
which was a theory that if you worked if
you were part of this death machinery
you were guilty whether or not you could
prove you killed person X Y or Z this
was in complete contradiction to been
Francis approach in the Isis group in
case so you had that controversy set up
which goes right up to the present then
he also bought his his his trials were
overshadowed by one case Ilsa Koch he
was the widow at the time the wife of
the Fuhrer the longest-serving
Bougainville current commander and she
was known as the [ __ ] of Buchenwald she
was known for her sadism for going
around and just torturing having
prisoners beaten
and for flaunting her sexuality and then
having prisoners picked off who
responded in any way to it and then
there are very lurid stories in the
press that she had also had prisoners
especially with tattoos taken away
killed and stripped and and lampshades
made of their skin a lot of this was was
some of this became dubious and
especially that latter part and later on
she was pardoned by actually her
sentence was reduced from a life
sentence to four years bye-bye clay and
and Denson was furious and there's a
whole uproar in Washington and by but
interestingly enough even when the
Germans the West Germany wanted to end
these trials as soon as she was let out
she was imprisoned by West Germany and
given another life sentence and she died
in prison she committed suicide in
prison well as you indicated after about
1948 there was the Allies war crimes
trials program really petered out and
they were instead of trying people they
were commuting sentences and granting
clemency and by 1958 pretty much
everyone who had been convicted but
hadn't been executed pretty quickly
after its sentence was free so Lawrence
I want to ask you what what what were
the reasons for this change that the
Allies feel that they had accomplished
what they'd set out to do with the
trials I said I think there are three
answers one answer is the Cold War the
second answer is the Cold War and the
third answer is the Cold War I mean I
think that was really kind of the
realities were at some point the United
States made the calculation that we
needed
West Germany as a dependable Ally
against our former Ally the Soviet Union
and it was really just a calculation of
trying to appease the Germans the
Germans turned against the Allied war
crimes program really really
aggressively at the time of the
Nuremberg trial before the International
Tribunal the Germans were actually quite
sympathetic or at least they express
perhaps they were to cow to express
their actual views but at least in a
polls that were taken by the Americans
they expressed support for the Nuremberg
trial when these additional trials were
conducted some of the ones that Andy was
describing then the Germans felt now the
Allies are just rubbing our face in our
crimes we want to make a transition to a
democratic society obviously in making
that transition to a democratic society
there are a tremendous number of former
Nazis who continued to occupy positions
of power particularly within the legal
apparatus of West Germany and those
persons had very little incentive to
support an aggressive war crimes program
and so once the Soviet Union emerged as
the principal antagonist of the United
States and once the United States
calculated that Germany was needed as an
ally then the Americans were willing to
do a lot in order to secure the support
of Germany and unfortunately that took
the form of basically commuting
sentences of perpetrators of genocide
and just one very specific example I
interviewed the man who became the head
of the first CIA base in Berlin there
was the OSS which was the predecessor
then the CIA base and he himself was a
German Jew who had left Germany as a
teenager in the 30s gone to Britain then
came to the United States became a
citizen joined the army and and then the
OSS and the CIA and so as this guy young
young head of this first CIA base in
Berlin he said you know we were I was
not interested in fighting the last war
they got rid of you know some of the big
guys it's time to move on and that was
the prevailing sentiment and even
despite his family ties he really just
felt that very strongly
well you've each written a book about
the pursuit of justice for Nazi crimes
and your books both focus particularly
on the era after
a line war crimes trial program but you
take very very different approaches so
Andrea your book focuses on specific
individuals who played very different
roles in the pursuit of justice
explain how you picked your subjects and
and and why you thought this was a good
way to approach the topic well I think
first of all you have to understand when
you say Nazi hunters which is a very
loose phrase and I know so many people
in the Justice Department so forth have
have qualms about it but there were two
essential groups there were the people
who were the government our military
prosecutors investigators and who had
the authority of governments behind them
and then there were I would call the
freelance Nazi hunters people like
Holocaust survivors like Stephen Visa
Thal most famously Tuvia Friedman later
Beata and Serge Claire's felt who made
it their mission to publicize and push
these issues when it was unpopular do so
and when that situation happened where
people were governments were dropping
this very quickly even people like Visa
and thawb fees install is often seen as
a very controversial character and but
everybody gives them a credit for
instance for keeping this issue alive
and not allowing people to forget it
and then you know the other thing that
intrigued me as a reporter for instance
covering the collapse of communism I'm
always struck by how history and
retrospect looks looks so inevitable you
know we say oh this must happen have
happened this way well in fact that's
not true in my experience and
individuals making decisions someone
like I say there are two things that
distinguish the people I write about
determination and for lack of a better
word or I think it's a good word hood
spot and you know friends demonstrated
hood spy by saying at age 27 I can take
on this biggest case by the way at one
point he had this famous incident where
as a young as in corporal Marlena
Dietrich came to see to to you to the
General Headquarters and he was told the
guard the latrine so she could take a
bath he guarded the bath and then at
that at a certain moment just walked
into the bath
and and when he was sure she was in it
and so impressed Dietrich that she
invited him to lunch with the generals
so these people had who it's but and but
in determination though not to be
stopped and so you had people like
friends and and and dents and who were
very very strongly motivated you had
Fritz Bower in Germany who was firma
from a secular Jewish family he would be
a social democrat gone into exile and
and and then came back and he was
determined to make the Germans face up
to the Past when it was incredibly
unpopular as Lawrence said when when
sentiment was running against it and
eventually orchestrated the Auschwitz
trial eventually provided a key tip for
the idol of Eichmann case and and yeah
so everywhere I and later on you had
people in the United States and in
France the Clarksville such do those of
you know is something about piata and
Serge Clairsville piata Clairsville was
not Jewish she grew up there herself her
father was in the German and German army
she came to Paris at an au pair fell in
love with Serge Claire's felt his father
had died in Auschwitz and she suddenly
learning about all this became this
passionate anti a
after the Nazis wherever she saw them
and when in a former Nazi became the
mayor at the the the Chancellor of West
Germany in 1968 she actually got onto a
stage like this where and sneaked it
snuck by with a press credential all
those newspaper people and and she
slapped him and shouted you now see now
this was the year at 1968 when you know
Bobby Kennedy had been assassinated the
Martin Luther King had been assassinated
she could have been shot but she did
this and so some of people took
incredibly dramatic actions great
so Lawrence you used the long Odyssey of
the John Demjanjuk case to tell this
story of the post-war pursuit of justice
can you summarize somewhat briefly the
DEM Janiak case ago
so demonic was a as some of you probably
recall he lived most of his adult life
in suburban Cleveland where he worked as
a machinist for Ford and he happened to
also be the subject of the lengthiest
and arguably most bizarre criminal case
to arise out of the Holocaust this is a
man who all told was tried four times he
was tried twice in the United States on
civil immigration charges that is for
having lied on his immigration forms and
he earned the dubious distinction of
being the only person in American
history to be twice stripped of his
naturalized US citizenship he was tried
once in Israel in the late 1980s as Ivan
Grozny as ivan the terrible' of
Treblinka and this was a really kind of
a spectacular case in Israel the only
other case that kind of rivals that is
of course the trial of Adolf Eichmann he
was condemned and sentenced to death
and his his appellate phase of a trial
happened to coincide with the unraveling
of the Soviet Union and what this meant
is that both defense lawyers and Israeli
prosecutors suddenly got access to
literally hundreds of thousands of pages
of documents that had been moldering in
a KGB files and what this evidence
indicated was that the Israelis had the
wrong guy now he had been convicted
almost exclusively on the basis of
eyewitness testimony of survivors of
Treblinka who swore with absolute
certainty to recognize in demonic their
former tormentor this legendarily
sadistic guard
these were survivors who when they
testified you know they went out of
their way of saying look I'm not like
someone who suffered the trauma of a
passing car accident where I caught a
fleeting glance of the person who
injured me I saw this guy Dan day out
for months on end and his image is
burned into my retina and yet when the
appellate phase had run its course the
Israeli Supreme Court was able to
conclude that they had got wrong that
they had misidentified to me on yoke
that this legendarily sadistic guard
named known as Ivan the Terrible was in
fact an entirely different Ukrainian
named Ivan Marchenko but what made the
whole thing kind of into sort of a legal
perfect storm is at the same time that
this evidence made clear that demonic
had not been Ivan the Terrible it also
made clear that he had been you know we
can call him I'm in the not-so-hot that
is that in fact he had been a guard but
not at Treblinka but it's sober bore and
an equally lethal Nazi dead camp death
camp and this led to another entirely
elaborate set of proceedings which
resulted in his deportation to Germany
in 2009 and in 2009 he stood trial in
Germany now as desire and then
not-so-hot of sobibor rather than Ivan
the Terrible of Treblinka and so I kind
of used this a very lengthy and observe
case as you say is kind of a conduit to
look at the larger legal struggles of
looking at many different cases
involving the effort to bring
perpetrators and also collaborators in
the Holocaust to justice well Iceland
trial
you've both mentioned that was really a
watershed event in the pursuit of
justice for Nazi crimes can you talk a
little bit each of you you know what you
what you think the impact of that case
was why it was so important yeah could I
just say one thing as pre loot to that
trial is yeah they we all think of the
the Eichmann trial and it created a bit
that this legend that the Israelis were
out there hunting for Nazis everywhere
and I went to Israel and in researching
in this book and and found that two the
two members of the team who led the team
that physically snatched Eichmann were
still alive at the time one is since
died but Rafi Eitan the commander of the
ground operation was there and and he's
still alive and I talked to him about it
and and at one point he said in 1953 I
went to Germany as a young Mossad agent
and I'm thinking Nazis Nazis Nazis he
says no it's not what you're thinking
yeah I went there because at the time
Israel needed to vet all the Jews coming
from Eastern Europe from the Soviet
Union Poland Hungary who were coming to
Israel they needed it for the population
but they also knew that as some of them
were being recruited by the KGB and
other Eastern intelligence agencies and
they'd be reporting back to their
capitals Warsaw or Budapest or Moscow
and then it would be going straight to
the Arab side that was our priority so I
wasn't even thinking about Nazis then so
and really that Israel lying is you know
the u.s. had his preoccupation is with
the Cold War Israel as its
preoccupations with just existing so but
by the late civil a 50s when they got
this tip that originated from Fritz
power that about Eichmann's presence in
in in Argentina at that point the origin
really was and this is again there's one
member of the prosecution team still
spell live Gabriel Bach he said our
concern was that the Holocaust was being
forgotten not just abroad but it was it
was not being talked about in Israel and
for the reason that young Israelis could
not understand how this could have
happened how people could have gone
through their death seemingly without
fighting in Israel you understood
fighting and death but Virna and that
this would be if they got Eichmann it'd
be a chance to explain this whole
process and ben-gurion at that point
authorized the operation once the leads
panned out which was a very long and
Gold story yeah the IceMen trial was the
great holocaust trial I mean if we go
back to what we were saying about
Nuremberg recalled Nuremberg was not in
the first instance a Holocaust trial it
was about aggressive war and in fact one
thing that also disturbed many Holocaust
survivors about the Nuremberg trial is
that the Nuremberg trial was a trial not
of the testimony of people who are
survived it was a trial by document he
was a trial in which the prosecutors
basically read thousands and thousands
of pages of captured Nazi documents into
the record and one of the consequences
of that trial by document at Nuremberg
was the famous British writer Rebecca
West covered the Nuremberg trial for the
Daily Telegraph in Britain and she
famously described Nuremberg as a
citadel of boredom and she said it was
boredom on a historic scale and part of
it was that it lacked the vibrancy of
having a human voice and David
ben-gurion and in particular the Israeli
attorney general who was the prosecutor
eyghon Gideon Hausner he very
specifically wanted to make a trial
which is opposed to Nuremberg would
really focus on the Holocaust and B
would be a trial in which lived history
would be told through the memory of
survivors and that is exactly how the
the trial unfolded and unfolded with
many many survivors testifying and both
ben-gurion and Hausner were astonished
by the success of the trial that is they
certainly wanted a trial as Andy
suggested for the purposes of trying to
teach a domestic audience about the
Holocaust
they were completely caught by surprise
at the degree to which the IceMen trial
riveted not simply a domestic audience
in Israel but an international audience
and it really is the event that put the
Holocaust on the map in West Germany and
it also put the Holocaust on the map in
the United States and in fact in many
ways I want to
I hope this formulation isn't confusing
but
in a certain way it created the
Holocaust as the event as we now know it
that is I think up until the time the
Eichmann trial we can say that the
extermination of the Jews of Europe was
seen as one of the features of the
Second World War after the ice cream
trial it starts to emerge in the way
that we see the Holocaust today which is
perhaps as the exemplary event of the
20th century and of course that
generated huge intellectual debate with
Hannah Arendt going to the trial with
her theories about about the trial and
whether it was Eichmann this minor
functionary who just just was carrying
out orders as he tried to portray
himself or was he a monster as others
portray themselves and then what do you
say if you if someone's a monster then
does that absolve other people who did
you say only the monsters did this and
so yeah it becomes a focal point not
just for you know no justice are not
justice and and and Holocaust studies
but human psychology at its most basic
level well it also it gave rise to many
of these famous psychology experiments
some of you might be familiar that
Milgram experiment I mean all these
things were kind of motivated with
trying to make sense of the psychology
of the perpetrator and you know so that
is also one of the very interesting
things that all these trials do that is
one of the things they do is they create
images of what it means to be a
perpetrator of these extreme crimes so
then in 1979 the United States Justice
Department creates the Office of Special
Investigation and gives it exclusive
authority to investigate and bring legal
action against Nazi criminals who are
living in the United States
so why in 1979 I haven't anything done
been done before why did the government
then at a time when almost nobody else
was trying Nazi criminals decide to
undertake this venture I think one of
the interesting things is tying as
Lauren suggested the Eichmann trial the
are the various earlier trials and how
this affected and across geographically
and
in time and I think the key moment one
of the key moments is 1964 when Simon
Wiesenthal again he hears about this
woman called her mean Brown Steiner and
he hears here's a story from some
survivors of my donek who's who are who
are talking about this vicious guard who
was called kabila which in Polish means
the mayor in other she was kicking
lashing out at prisoners gratuitously
and they say what happened to this woman
and visa Thal eventually traces her she
had Hugh she was from Austria and she
had served briefly in prison in Austria
and then she marries an American by the
name of Russell Ryan and she becomes
mrs. Russell Ryan and is living in
Queens and Joel Ellie Feld who some of
you know later becomes the editor of the
New York Times is a cub reporter and he
said go out and we have this tip from
this guy visa Thal figured that there
that there's this woman including Queens
he knocks on our doors he writes the
story in 1964 and until it takes until
1971 for a for for the ANS to finally
strip her of her citizenship and and and
and and she is sent to Germany
eventually he's convicted there and
spends several years in prison in
Germany but it begins to raise question
then other people say well who else is
in the United States
and they are and and there are various
reports the I NS is supposed to vet
these things and not to conduct trials
war crimes trials because you can't try
them for it but if they came in under
false pretenses then then you can strip
them of their citizenship and there's
several such cases and in the early 70s
a Elizabeth Holtzman who say the
congresswoman from Brooklyn begins to
hear about these things and she says
well at first I thought the brown
Steiner case was an aberration and then
I hear there's some sort of list that
the AI NS has of Nazi war criminals in
the United States of about fifty-three
people and the I asked Commissioner
comes and and testifies before a
subcommittee and she asked do you have
this list
he says yes and she says I practically
dropped over my chair and then begins
this whole battle the IAS has clearly
not handled and not investigated these
cases and eventually forces through the
creation of the OSI the Office of
Special Investigations where people like
yourself worked and and that becomes the
unit that finally gets back into the
business of identifying people who are
Nazi war criminals and and stripping
them of their citizenship deporting them
if possible and if possible getting them
tried someplace else
all each step along the way we could
discuss and each one a very difficult
one but at least establishing the
principle that if you're not a you're a
Nazi war criminal you're not welcome in
the United States you may have slipped
in after the war especially when with
all those displaced persons obviously
some small percentage of them who might
have been involved in Nazi war crimes
and and pretending to be someone else
than they were so Lawrence I know as I
was creative it was represented a pretty
new approach to how to go about this
pursuit of justice
what would you say where are the
strengths and the weaknesses of the OSI
model well it goes back a little bit to
what Andy was saying is that these
American prosecutors they're prosecuting
civil charges that is they're basically
taking crimes of genocide crimes against
humanity and they're treating it as if
it's lying on your immigration form and
so in a certain way you're kind of
torturing history by trying to digest
this
you know these horrific crimes into
something that is really kind of just a
civil wrong now the reason the
prosecutors do this is you know it's a
very clever and an important strategy
because also as Andy suggested these are
crimes that took place outside the
United States in which the perpetrators
were not American citizens at the time
and in which the victims were not
American citizens so American courts had
no jurisdiction to bring criminal
charges against these individuals and so
kind of they developed this very clever
strategy of using civil immigration
charges as the way to
about it but again I think that had its
limitations the other thing to mention
is that even bringing these immigration
cases as Andy also suggested it was
incredibly complicated and it basically
required that you could probably tell us
even better than I could it required the
you know the OSI within the Department
of Justice